[Music]
from calorie counter portion sizes
we wanted to find out all the
differences between uk and us starbucks
this is food wars
now hot coffees in the uk come in four
sizes
[Music]
firstly we have a short coffee which is
eight ounces
the short eight ounces then we have a
tall coffee
which is 12 ounces next we have the tall
next 12 ounces it's a grande coffee
which comes in at 16 ounces then we got
the grande
16 ounces aventi or 20 ounces
ah sensational and the biggest one the
venti
20 ounces
in case you're wondering it's called the
venti because 20
in italian is venti tuento
just to double check we're going to
measure the largest hot coffee in the uk
[Music]
so our venti coffee actually came to
closer to 18 ounces sort that out
starbucks
where's my two ounces now i'm going to
measure
the venti coffee which should be
20 ounces minus a few sips
wait
getting prepared
whoa come on i did not drink that much
oh starbucks that's not no that's not
even two that's like an ounce
the cold coffees in the uk come in three
sizes
the tall the tall 12 ounces
grand bay we got the grande and
fenty here's where things get kind of
weird our venti iced
is 24 ounces and we have another size up
20 right
and that is 30 ounces
[Music]
so a uk cold venti is exactly 20 ounces
yeah 21. i thought this was supposed to
be 24.
how many fluid ounces
venti iced
24 how much is it 21
starbucks with the ice you still don't
have enough
i'm taking a sip of every single drink
i'm taking a sip of every single
drink let's do this
let's compare some seemingly identical
drinks to see how much they match up
under the hood
so a venti latte in the uk contains 235
calories
7.9 grams of fat 21.1 grams of sugar
and 225 milligrams of caffeine and in
the u.s
the same venti latte has 250 calories
and that's 9 grams of fat and 150
milligrams of caffeine and you know i'm
taking a sip
kind of cold it's been sitting out for
hours so our lattes got more sugar
more calories and more fat the trinity
of deliciousness is what i call it
let's try something a little heavier if
you were to order a venti caramel
frappuccino from a uk starbucks
it would contain 426 calories 61.1 grams
of sugar
and 117 milligrams of caffeine harry
your frappuccino's looking a little sad
there buddy looks like all your whipped
cream melted so
here's a pro tip from the usa
470 calories 74 carbs
73 of which are sugar and 120 milligrams
of caffeine
damn oh yuck yuck that's what that
tastes like
now it's important to remember that for
cold drinks like frappuccinos
the us venti is actually four fluid
ounces larger than the uk's
if you were to do the math to work out
the nutrition per fluid ounce the uk
actually beats the us in virtually every
metric
let's see if we can get any clues as to
why from the ingredients
now in the uk a cappuccino from
starbucks contains just two ingredients
milk and brewed espresso and in the u.s
our cappuccinos are made from
milk and brewed espresso look at that
same thing finally
[Music]
now for the most part the hot coffees in
both countries are just those two
ingredients in different quantities
things get a little bit more complicated
once you start to add things like syrups
however
for example in the uk if you add caramel
syrup to your cappuccino it adds the
following ingredients
sugar water natural flavoring
concentrate of apple
carrot hibiscus molasses citric acid and
potassium sorbet
whereas our caramel syrup has sugar corn
syrup butter
cream milk salt uh water heavy cream
non-fat dry milk natural flavors
salt mono digly psoriasis i don't know
what that word is
um soy lecithin and sulfides the point
is
our caramel syrup is actual caramel in
it how do you like that
now let's try something with a lot more
ingredients this is a
java chip frappuccino from the uk and it
contains the following
ice ice milk milk coffee frappuccino
syrup
which is sugar water natural flavor salt
xanthan gum
ladies and gentlemen it is a food wars
first the first time
something in the uk has an ingredients
list longer than something in the u.s
time to celebrate baby
[Music]
here is everything you can only find on
the menu at a uk starbucks
and this is everything you can get in a
u.s starbucks
now we'll start with a quick disclaimer
one of the big selling points of
starbucks is that you can heavily
customize pretty much everything on the
menu
to save ourselves doing a million
different combinations of exclusive
items what we're going to do is focus
mostly on things that are on the menu as
they are
with just like a few combinations of
syrups and toppings that you can get in
one or the other
firstly we have this cute little cortado
secondly
we have a cold foam cappuccino which is
like an iced cappuccino with just some
foam on top of it
then we have some temporary seasoning
exclusive so at the moment you can get a
peanut butter cup frappuccino in the uk
as well as a chocolate s'mores
frappuccino which sounds pretty damn
good in the u.s along with the blonde
roast you can get in the uk we also have
a dark roast and we have something
called the pike place roast
now that roast is a tribute to the first
starbucks that's near the pike place
market
in seattle washington i've been to that
starbucks it's fine
exclusive to the us we have the caramel
cloud macchiato
oh i do not like that the mocha
cookie crumble frappuccino
uh the caramel ribbon crunch frappuccino
i mean the regular caramel one was gross
let's see how this one is
oh god it's worse oh it's so much worse
and
we also have this a vanilla sweet cream
cold brew
the ice has melted
woof i bet that was good six hours ago
when it was made
and what we've done is combine as many
uk exclusives as we can into one drink
which i'm calling the uk only
we've got some almond some sugar-free
caramel some sugar-free hazelnut and
some mango
which is going to be an interesting mix
oh that is sweet
and of course at the starbucks in the us
we have our own unique customizations
for instance
pineapple ginger syrup raspberry syrup
toffee nut syrup
a cascara topping cinnamon dolce
sprinkles
we have chocolate cinnamon nutmeg and
vanilla powders
and a whole range of cold foams so
of course i went ahead and add all those
things put in
to one drink which i'm calling the usa
only
mm-hmm
oh man that's weird
nothing in that works together
the cafe started baby it started
[Music]
starbucks now this series isn't called
drink wars and thankfully starbucks
has lots of food items here are some
things you'll only find on the menu at a
uk starbucks
let's start with the bakery section here
in the uk on the bakery menu you will
find
a chocolate chunk shortbread cookie you
will find this delightful
little gingerbread barista man you'll
find this panoraza
we also have some luxury fruit toast
which comes with these little cute pots
of jam and then finally we've got a
cinnamon swell which is kind of just a
cinnamon roll our breakfast options are
slightly limited
most of what we have is a range of
breakfast rolls which is just kind of
like a breakfast sandwich in the uk but
served on crusty white bread
some options include a bacon sandwich
bacon sandwiches are a pretty big deal
over here for that moment ketchup
and then also if you want something a
little bit more you can go for an
all-day breakfast sandwich which is
bacon sausage
and egg all in one roll here are the u.s
exclusive food items so a lot of
different breakfast sandwiches
for starbucks this one right here is
the impossible meat sandwich
spinach egg and feta cheese wrap
this is my go-to one love it these egg
bites these little
i'm gonna definitely pronounce this
wrong these little suit v egg wraps
sued v i'll be straight up i've never
had one of these
holy these are so good
oh my god a lot of baked goods like this
little friendly guy just in time for the
holiday season a little snowman cake pop
a bunch of different varieties of sugar
cookies i got this one because i think
it looks the nicest but i don't want
this at all
oh but you know i do love dude danishes
especially cheese danishes we also got
scones
so one with the blueberry scone look at
harry's face on there let's go in here
sorry to break it to joe but that is not
a scone a few things to point out
firstly it's pronounced scone not scone
secondly they should all the marshmallow
dream bar aka a rice crispy
treat what are we doing
we're going to starbucks in the morning
and we're getting cookies and rice
krispie treats for breakfast
no no
they got bagels i asked for cream cheese
and they forgot
pumpkin cream cheese muffin it's got
pumpkin
little glob of cream cheese in it right
there muffins are okay in the morning
i'm pro
morning muffin last and probably least
because i've never
had one nor have i ever wanted one
starbucks in the us have a lot of what
they call protein boxes
chicken and quinoa looks like a
salad you guys have pretty much all the
lunch options that we have in terms of
like paninis sandwiches
and wraps one thing i did want to
highlight was this which is a
cheese and marmite mini ciabatta so
marmite as some of you will know
is a spread that's quite popular in the
uk it's like the byproduct of making
beer
when the yeast ferments it kind of
leaves like a sludge on the bottom of
the tank
and that is mermaid but it somehow
tastes really good
harry no tamarmite it's bad stop it
so on top of classic english breakfast
tea we also have some exclusive teas to
the uk
so we'll start with the jasmine pearl
green tea which is just our exclusive
version of the green tea
here we've got something called a youth
berry tea which apparently helps keep
you young
here is some chamomile tea which is
great if you want something to relax
before bed
then we've got some frozen teas as well
so this is a frozen iced tea made with
apple and kiwi
this is a frozen iced tea with tropical
mango and then this
is a frozen strawberry and lime tea here
in the u.s we have a lot of exclusive
teas too
these are those exclusive teas uh for
hot ones we have a
jade citrus mint uh a peach tranquility
tea
i think they missed a trick they're not
calling it the peach tranquility
counter blade came up with that not me
uh the
revved up tea right there and then for
the cold ones we got the
royal english breakfast tea why don't
you guys have the iced
royal english breakfast tea uh
a matcha lemonade tea a iced guava black
tea
and the passion tango iced tea
hmm
you